foreign
what am I calling you uh anxiety anxiety
you can call me anxiety you can call me
princess
anxieties are the name you go by at the
club okay cool yes anxiety it is
all right anxiety
anxiety oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally St Louis Missouri St
Louis yeah tell me about your family
yeah uh my family is kind of all over
the place
um very old school
um but not in a way where I couldn't
express myself
I feel like I got everything I ever
wanted when I was growing up but I still
didn't live the way that I was supposed
to live
I have a younger brother
um he is a huge drug addict he kind of
went the other spectrum of the board out
of the family
uh it's
one of the things where I've been really
just trying to keep my family afloat
which is why I do what I do
um they've been my rock
um they support me in everything I do no
matter what it is they have my back I
don't know where I'd be without them you
support your family I do I support my
family with everything I do yeah back in
St Louis
yep
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um my childhood was very kind of crazy
um
my mom was not really around mentally uh
she was there but she wasn't like there
she had a lot of problem she was mis uh
diagnosed so she was on a lot of
medication she was like a zombie
my grandma pretty much raised me
my grandma she
she was just kind of you know dealing
with taking care of everybody back then
that it was just so much for her that
she just she really
only wanted to drink that was that was
her Escape
I feel like every time she gets stressed
out she drinks she was just she's still
like that today
um so my childhood was kind of like okay
then for yourself because no one was
really
was really around to be able to do
certain things for me
um but I basically raised my little
brother
my dad
um
my data kind of disappeared when we were
about well I was 12 when my dad
disappeared so my dad was not in the
picture
uh he where me and my little brother are
protected from him for 50 years we
haven't seen him since
um
I mean I had I had a normal childhood I
think it was just all over the place
um me and my mom she'd pick us up in the
middle of the night and we just go
somewhere
like she would take us to another state
she had this like
I don't know what not an ambition but
she just like wake up and wake us up and
she'd be like okay pack a bag we're
leaving
so you moved around a lot we moved
around a lot and hotel to hotel the
hotel there we've never really had a
stable home
it's kind of I mean it's still kind of
like that I mean you know I live I still
live with all my family because I'm
taking care of them just like they take
care of me
I live uh I still live with my grandma
and honestly like I prefer that because
my Grandma has a lot going on with her
so
but yeah my job has been
all over the place
and how is it that you're supporting
your family uh when I dance and I do
events and stuff uh I just take the
money and I do what I can to help help
them out I really don't think that you
know they could do it without me they
always tell me if it you know if it
wasn't for you we would be in the
streets you're based in a particular
City or you travel around I travel a lot
um I am probably only ever in St Louis
maybe a week to two weeks at a time
I go all over the place I've been South
Carolina North Carolina Florida
uh Texas I'm really big in Houston
um I come out here a lot I spent a
couple years living in Huntington Beach
California with uh my mom for a while
there I have my mom move out here with
me so I could take care of her and my
little brother which ended up going
sideways and they went back to St Louis
I lived in Tennessee I stayed in
Nashville for a while
uh I just I've really have been I've
bounced all over the place and dancing
in strip clubs and all these all of them
every single every single state uh the
only state I did not dance in was
Tennessee because they required a
dancing license and
I I knew I wasn't going to be there long
enough to like why spend the money on
something I know I'm not going to use so
I just didn't dance in Tennessee but I
was only in Tennessee for four months so
so tell me about the
the lifestyle that you lead now
um the lifestyle I Live Now
um well drugs drugs it sounds like
you're not a part of your life drugs are
not a part of my life I smoke weed I do
smoke weed I'm a heavy drinker
I like the social drink I like to drink
when I'm bored but as far as actual
drugs go I've never tried them I've seen
too many of my my own personal family
members just get caught up in it and
just turn into complete monsters
my especially my little brother he's
he's a prime example of that
um I can't keep him off of it I can't
keep him out of jail
um constantly relapsing and every time
you know I've had the opportunity hey
you want you want this you want that
I can't do it because I don't want to
change who I am I don't want to lose
myself into those type of situations
um so I stay very clear away from the
drugs but I do smoke
um I honestly don't think I'd know what
I would do without it because it's the
only thing that calms me down
so yeah so tell me about working in a
strip club that's
what have you learn about men from from
working what do I learn about me how
long have you been doing it first off
okay I've been dancing for nine years
I started when I was 17. in fact I
learned a lot I have learned so much I I
think
I started out very shy whenever I first
started I was 17 years old I started at
this little Club in Brooklyn Illinois
and it was named Roxy's at the time
and it was fully nude
and that was my first experience uh it
was just
that little bit of money that I was
making was more than I ever like I ever
touched that I was a child I feel like I
was still a child back then so to me it
was still a big deal but I was making
500 to a thousand dollars in a night at
a time when I was 17. and I stopped
because
I was like one of the guys grabbed me by
my throat and like pinned me against the
wall and I was terrified
so I stopped for a year got me a regular
job and then I was like I can't do this
I miss that kind of money once you get a
taste of that kind of money it's hard to
it's hard to go back it's really hard to
work a regular job and to live a regular
life and I came out here uh in 2018 in a
car with a hundred dollars to my name
and I just
didn't have nowhere to go so I was like
you know what I need to I need to dance
again
and so I started dancing in a club
called Fantasy Castle in Long Beach
and I worked there ever since
um up until covet hit and I loved it I
learned it so much I went from being
this shy little girl
to someone who's aggressive and who
takes charge I know how to deal with
people I know how to talk to people I'm
more open I'm not like I don't want to
talk I'm not the type to sit there and
be like okay I'll just wait for them to
come to me no
um
I like the fact that I've changed
because I've gotten to be a very
well-known a very very well-known
stripper I have a big fan base of
clientele who knows who I am
um I can get booked like the snap of the
fingers people want me just to be inside
their Club they don't have to
wait for me to reach out before that was
impossible I couldn't do that
so it's just like the whole nine years
of what I've taken from it the men
that's come and go I've met some amazing
men married I they've even brought their
wives or their girlfriends
uh some of them were too much some of
them were very handsy and ignorant
but I learned how to deal with it I
learned how to to uphold myself I've
been drugged twice
at the club in my entire nine years you
put something in your drink yep I was
drugged uh it was a very very terrible
experience
I was sick for two weeks
um
I couldn't work I couldn't do nothing
and it was terrifying it was very
terrifying I remember feeling like I
felt different because I can drink and I
could hold my alcohol and I knew I was
feeling different and I remember going
into the bathroom
texting the DJ I texted the DJ and I was
like help me and I blacked out I woke up
to some random girl with her hands in my
mouth trying to get me to throw up
even the security had to literally carry
me out to the car and drive me home and
the next day I went to the hospital and
it was just
I I had to take I had to take a break
so yeah it's a stressful lifestyle isn't
it it's
it is very stressful I mean it's it's
got its pros and cons but it takes a
very big toll on your mental health more
than anything because it's a lot of
energy coming at you at one time with a
lot of people that you're meeting it's
it's a lot of
it's a lot of strength that you're using
it puts your body through a lot you
really put your body through so much
when you dance especially when you're
dancing from
you know 6 p.m to 5 o'clock in the
morning or 6 p.m to 2 A.M for me I would
go in when the club open at 11 o'clock
in the morning and I work till 2 30 and
at night well 2 30 in the morning and
then I'd leave from that club and I go
to an overnight club and I'll work from
3 A.M to 6 o'clock in the morning and I
would do this every day I would not take
a day off
and it was rewarding because of the type
of money that I was making when you make
that type of money you don't ever want
to go back to anything else like you
don't want to stop it's like motivation
you know and when covet hit it was just
like a whole different ball game I lost
my house I had a one bedroom apartment
in Huntington Beach right across from
the beach it was 4 200 a month I was
doing so
I feel like I was doing so good and I
finally reached everywhere where I
wanted to be I bought me out a brand new
car
um but I lost everything I got into a
car accident
um coming home from work I got hit by a
drunk driver
and I lost my car
and then
I lost my apartment because I did not
have a club to work at because all the
clubs were they were all shut down here
in California
so I packed my stuff up and I moved to
Houston Texas and I started dancing in
Houston Texas but the money wasn't the
same because kovid everybody was losing
everything it was harder to find work
um I started doing webcaming and doing
things like that to kind of fill my time
up a little bit that kind of helped a
little bit only fans was definitely big
so I was touching into that's when I
really started stepping foot into only
fans and kind of making that move from
okay I can't dance right now but I can
dance at home on a pole in my living
room type thing on live so that's really
what I was doing but yeah
crazy how that works and you make good
money doing it I did I'm it wasn't what
I was it wasn't anywhere what I was
touching the club fans I'm talking about
stripping yes stripping in general yes
uh
when I first started I thought 200 was
200 a night was great then as I came up
I started making 500 a night I was like
wow okay then I went up and it just like
as I was getting better and more
experienced my money went from making
200 a night to almost 5 000 a night
and I was doing private parties for
famous rappers I was traveling into the
hills and getting booked for events I
started working for bigger clubs with
bigger names started traveling and when
you travel you
there's not a lot of girls who look like
me out there which I love I love that my
image stands out I want to be unique I
want to look different and people look
at me and they're like wow like
you're definitely something and your
Energy's great your personality is great
even though I'm a little intimidating at
first they like you know then they
approach me they're like I'm kind of
scared to talk to you because I don't
know how you're going to be then they
talk to me like wow where have you been
all my life
I'm a very like I have a lot of Charisma
and I could talk and I love conversation
so that helps with my money I feel like
what have you learned about men from
doing this
uh
I feel like every like when it comes to
the guys that walk into the clubs
I feel like everybody just needs
somebody to have fun with
and to talk to
I really don't feel like it's
as raunchy as people think it is when
you know I was on the outside looking in
it's like you expect the strip club to
be one thing but it's in reality it's
not it's just one big house party
if you really think about it and a lot
of guys are when they come in there
they're just looking for somebody to
talk to they want somebody to talk to
they want someone to drink with they
want someone to have fun with
and some of them want to take you home
majority of them want to take you home
you know and it's just like
that's all it is that's all I've learned
from men they just want to have a good
time and not have a woman just screaming
at them in their face all the time and
that's the whole purpose of going to a
strip club is to have fun and to drink
cheap and to throw some money around and
boost your ego a bit tell me about the
back rooms at strip clubs
oh the back rooms and ship clubs uh
they are expensive VIPs are
crazy expensive you're paying a thousand
dollars for 30 minutes
um sometimes they go up from there I
honestly I've never done I've never done
anything like extras you know like I've
never done that I've never had to but
however like you know you get those
customers you get those guys who come in
they're like let me take you to the VIP
and you have to be like okay look this
is what I do this is what I don't do
some respect it some do not some are
drunk and handsy and they will try to
take advantage of you I don't like doing
VIP rooms a lot unless I'm very
comfortable with
who I'm speaking to I have to really
feel your vibe to really go into the
back room
I feel like
it's sometimes a good break from
in the middle of the club rather than
being on the floor and being on stage
and maybe not even making you think
that's a guaranteed amount that you're
making when you go into one of them
rooms I was paid two Grands for a 30
minute VIP room just to watch the guy
who wanted me in there to [ __ ] another
girl
so I literally just stood there while
they had sex
and
I was like cool and I get paid 2 000 for
this because it's a thousand per person
and the girl wasn't even a stripper she
was just a customer just drunk she's
like I want to go
and he was like you want to go she's
like yeah I want to go
so he brought her in with us but I was
okay that's a thousand for you thousand
for her he paid it up front we went to
the VIP room and for those 30 minutes
all they did was have sex and I just I
just stood there like this
you get it
that's all I did VIP rooms could be fun
but they that's mainly honestly
not really no I'm I actually I've met
some really great guys from being in the
club some of my best friends uh they
I've met inside of the club and they
honestly just go in there to have a
drink because drinks are cheaper than
the bars and strip clubs and they want
someone to talk to they want someone you
know to rub them like rub their ego up
and
someone the majority of my friends came
from the strip club they're like family
to me so dear friend because you work so
much it sounds like do you have friends
outside of this life outside of this
lifestyle yeah
no I don't I feel like all my friends
are in the industry it's hard I have
tried dating and being friends with
people outside of this lifestyle and
it's impossible because I've really I've
had like I've dated somebody I tried to
date somebody who I met on Twitter or
not Twitter Tinder
I tried Tinder for a month and it was
awful
um they realized I was a stripper I was
like they were like what do you want to
do for your first date and this is how I
this I do it I was like let's go to a
strip club drink and throw somebody
around that's what I want to do for my
first date that's what I find fun
and they looked at me like what you want
to do what I've never I've never had a
woman like come to me like wanting to go
to a strip club so I was like yeah let's
do it
and we had fun but then he realized that
I was a stripper and he started to get
to know me a little bit more he was like
I'm sorry I can't be with you your
lifestyle is too much for me it's too
much and I had so much respect for that
man because he was so honest about it it
wasn't more like him just trying to have
sex with me he really respected the fact
he's like I cannot date you I cannot be
with you because you are that that is
what your lifestyle is you learn
something real he wanted yeah and you
lose a difference I lived in a different
lifestyle and when people view strippers
as
something that they're you know which
someday I can't say all of them but
there are some strippers who do all that
they do sell [ __ ] they do you know all
that extra stuff on the side me
personally I don't and the majority of
my friends don't
but it's like that's the stigma that
comes with strippers so it's just kind
of you know
one of that but that guy ended up
becoming someone who's I'm I mean I'm
still really good friends with him to
the day
but my lifestyle it is a lot and
I don't I really don't see myself
leaving it I it's just you know I'm 26
years old and I know there's an
expiration date you can't be a stripper
forever but it's like
I love what I do
I don't think I could change that and
the money I make just just to be with
somebody so all my friends all the
relationships I get into
I mean
you gotta accept my lifestyle
just work affect you emotionally
sometimes it's about ways uh when people
I care about or I love they like to they
like to call me out my name
um they like to bring up what I do for a
living and sometimes that takes a toll
on me because it's like you know I get
in those moods where I'm like damn like
always going to be looked at like a hoe
I'm not ever going to be looked at and
being taken seriously
the way that I want to be taken
seriously because of what I do for a
living and sometimes that does get to me
emotionally sometimes it's very hard
I'll be sitting on the bathroom floor
crying because it's like am I ever gonna
find love
like will I ever really get to be loved
the way that I want to be loved
because every time I pour my all into
somebody
my past and what I do now
always gets thrown in my face so
emotionally that takes the biggest toll
on me that's the only downfall of being
a dancer and being in this life your
life is so fast that
you're always going to be looked at a
certain way you're always going to be
judged a certain way
and it's just to the point where you've
got to not care and that's
a lot easier said than done so
many women do this work
no
you're not not everybody personality
traits yeah thick skin right you have to
have very thick skin you have to be
aggressive uh a lot of them don't
survive
the world like the lifestyle they get
caught up in drugs they get caught up in
in hoeing they get caught up in doing so
much more they end up getting you know
all The Pimps that you got to deal with
that come up in the club some girls they
they fall for it and you never see them
again
and it's just like
you gotta really stand your ground and
be like me and you have to be mean as a
dancer you could be in the back getting
dressed and you can get stabbed in the
dressing room by another female
like it's it's ruthless it's a very hard
lifestyle it's not as easy as everybody
makes a scene it's not like the movies
I think uh P Valley was the most
accurate description of
dancing
and not every female is built for it
ever just stand back and look at how
crazy this lifestyle you've carved out
carved out for yourself is definitely
all the time did you ever have dreams of
doing something else other than this I
do I have big I have big goals I
actually I mean I have a criminal law
degree
I spent two years I got an associate
degree in criminal law I went to Paul
Mitchell's Beauty School twice uh one in
St Louis and one in South Carolina
Charleston South Carolina
and then I'm currently in college for
business project management because I
want to purchase homes and completely
remodel them and flip them so I have
bigger goals for myself because I know
that there's an expiration to this I'm
not nobody dances just
to dance there's always a reason
and honestly for me it's to build up as
much money as I can to build a better
life for myself
so that's the way that I look at it I'm
like all of this can be gone like that
it could be gone so quick and you're
saving money yes you have to it's not
easy sometimes I'll have a hundred
dollars left in my bank account but
a week later I'll be up again
um I have a lot of family I take care of
I have a lot I have a lot of
responsibilities my own
I don't do student loans I don't you
know that I pay everything out of pocket
so when it comes down to it it's like
okay
I need something that I can really
be great at and do when I'm done with
this part of my life when I outgrow this
part of my life
because like I said what's more
important to You Love or Money
see I feel like I feel like it's a
little bit of both because I feel for me
personally it sounds like it's a time
sensitive question because right now
you're all about the money right now I
am but I just got out see I was I just
got out of a relationship and
he wanted to change me completely he
didn't want me dancing he didn't want me
doing anything he cut me off from
everything so I'm starting from the
ground up because I invested a lot of
money into that man and I realized I was
like what am I doing
because I want to chase love because I
want to be loved
I'm broke now I have nothing to my name
everything I worked so hard for I have
to rebuild I have to start over
why would I do that
and it clicked in me it's like okay
I need to make sure my future for myself
is stable do I want love yes of course I
definitely want love I want to be loved
I I always have and I believe in fairy
tales I'm I still believe in all the
movie stuff like I feel like every
female does or right now I'm just like
I feel like I've been hurt so much and
nobody respects what I do nobody can
accept me for who I am that it's just
I need to focus on what I'm doing I need
to focus on bettering my future level
always come
I mean
there's always you know that time to get
serious but right now I'm still I'm not
even 30 yet
so I feel like this is where I need to
keep my mind at
what are you proudest of in your life
honestly
I think what I'm proud of the most is
that I've never
I've never let like lost my
my morals I never done something that I
was not that I didn't want to do
I feel like that is I'm so proud of
myself for that because no matter how
broke I am no matter how dumb I am I I
still myself I've not lost myself
and that is my protests my proudest
thing is so many girls get caught up in
this I even though I'm deep in it I
never lost who I am I'm still the same
person I always have been and to me that
that is what I'm most proud of the fact
that I could take care of my family and
I never had to do anything that I did
not agree with or that broke my morality
that's my biggest accomplishment
you work in clubs that are fully nude
some some are fully nude some are just
topless yeah yeah
getting fully nude in in front of a room
of strangers is that
different it's not it's not hard at
first it was at first but I started
fully new dancing at 17 so my fear of
that kind of like you know like I've had
nine years so I'm very comfortable and
very confident I love being on stage I
just I know that whenever I walk on
stage everybody's gonna be like right
there just and the feeling of having
money like just coming down on you it's
intoxicating like it's like oh my it's
you know
and it feels amazing and you focused on
your own
like
how you moving on stage and how
everybody's screaming your name and like
cheering you on just throwing money at
you that makes you want to do more that
makes you want to take it all off and
make more because you can see their
reactions
when you become a stripper you're an
Entertainer
and being an Entertainer is amazing so
once you reach that confidence in
yourself and your body confident and you
feel great and you love who you are
you're just you're indestructible it's
an amazing feeling
amazing
tell me about your face tattoos
no face tattoos I started getting them
when I was 16. yeah if you have 100 your
left eye it says anxiety yep I just got
that uh recently like a month ago not
even a month ago hasn't even been a
month yet and your brow you have two yes
I have 777 and a heart and then I have
Wanderlust and then I have this little
like um sting of sword from Lord of the
Rings using face tattoos or
smart move
given that you're not going to be in
this line of work forever correct you
know I was a little worried about it but
at the same time I feel like no matter
what I'm always gonna be an Entertainer
and I Want To Be My Own Boss
when you're Your Own Boss it's not going
to matter
what you look like and I feel like once
you really get to know somebody like
like I said earlier you look at me I'm a
little intimidating but I start talking
and you're like wow
you're very educated you're you're very
like you know good with your words and
you know how to hold a conversation
and I feel like that's more important
than the ink on my body but my ink on my
body represents who I am and it's always
a conversation starter always I do get
profiled I do get looked at a certain
way
but I'm very confident in who I am and
and I love it I love expressing myself I
love looking different I just I think
that the tattoos
really Define like like tell a story
about who I am
and that's what I want I want to be able
to tell a story how did you get the name
anxiety
I have very very bad anxiety very bad
anxiety I it honestly started with my
Instagram
uh when I first started dancing I was
going by my real name and then I
realized how dangerous that was because
I was being stalked
and people were literally trying to
follow me home
and it was just like how did you find my
name like how did you find my personal
social media how did you find my phone
number so I cut that off as soon as I
could and when I moved from here well
from St Louis to come out here
um back in 2018 I had to have a social
media profile built
so I built it up and I've been anxiety
princess ever since and I have princess
tatted on my lower stomach
and then I have the anxiety on my face
so
yeah
exactly what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson the most
important lesson is that people are
going to come and go money comes and
goes you just need to live your life how
you want to live it because you only
have one life to live
as long as you are happy with the
choices you make
you shouldn't care about what anybody
else says or thinks that's one of the
biggest lessons I've learned
growing like growing in in life
is I'm not here to please people
even though I am pleasing people I'm not
here to please people
you have to be unique you have to stand
on your own two feet and you have to be
aggressive and take what you want
because you're not going to get and
you're not going to get far in life if
you don't take what you want
and that it stuck with me
and I feel like I've grown so much
standing on that lesson
that I'm really happy I learned it
all right anxiety thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck with everything you're
doing thank you so much thank you very
much